Kevin McCarthy is officially out as the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
Mr McCarthy is the first speaker in
history to be ousted from the job by a
vote and he is out because Republican
Congressman Matt Gates led a rebellion
of just eight Republicans to vote
against the speaker since the GOP
majority in the house is so thin eight
Republicans was all it took to defect
and along with the unified votes of the
Democrats who didn't to vote to save
McCarthy they all brought McCarthy's
brief tenure to a close here is
Congressman Gates defending the uprising
look at that big ass look at that big
juicy booty sorry that was an audio clip
of AOC over a picture of ilhan Omar
licking her lips literally licking her
lips while staring at the backside of
Congressman Gates yesterday I'm not sure
how that video got in there here is Matt
Gates defending the uprising Kevin
McCarthy is the Speaker of the House of
Representatives and he has failed to
take a stand where it matters so if he
won't I will I make no apologies for
defending the right of every hardworking
American to afford a decent life for
themselves and their families and we
have a greater opportunity to do that
and to build coalitions under new
leadership we have to rip off the
Band-Aid we have to get back on a better
course and Mr Speaker I don't know how
this vote's going to go usually when a
vot comes to this floor it's pretty
predetermined and this one I'm not so
sure but I am sure that we've made the
right argument that this place deserves
single subject spending bills that we
should have 72 hours to read a bill that
something that spends more than $100
million shouldn't be put on the
suspension agenda such that we can't
amend it and there shouldn't be Secret
side deals made on a continuing
resolution to lump Ukraine in with
border security that is a that is not
right for Ukraine or border security
because it fails to give either of those
issues the dignity that they would
require let's get our act together let's
get on with it let's vacate the chair
and let's get a better speaker I yeld
back all fair points all fair the only
thing that wasn't totally fair about
that was the Tailoring on Matt Gates's
jacket he needs a better tailor but
otherwise he sounded great he looked
great he raised a lot of totally legit
points but now the question that we are
left with
is what
now what happens now McCarthy wasn't
great but he was far from the worst in
fact this is probably damning with faint
praise but it's still true Kevin
McCarthy is probably the most
conservative speaker that Republicans
have had since Joe Martin in the 1950s
he was certainly better than Paul Ryan
certainly better than John Boehner
arguably he was more conservative even
than nuk ingrish but he lost the trust
of some key conservatives so now he's
out and now there is a vacancy for the
worst job in all of American politics
right now text nolles to 200 300 for
most homeowners window replacement is
not something that they've done before
for many it's not something that they
want to do but something that they've
got to do have you put off replacing the
windows in your home because it's too
expensive then I've got great news you
can now get a free inhome window
consultation and a free quote from
Renewal by Anderson I heard totally
unsolicited from a carpenter who just
listened to me do a read for Renewal by
Anderson he wrote he said Mike I just
want to let you know of all the homes
that I go and see and work on the ones
that have Windows from Renewal by
Anderson they've got the best work for
sure and coincidentally I have a cousin
who works for Renewal by Anderson he's
been telling me about them for years
years before they ever came on this show
so I've heard a lot of great stuff about
them and you're going to see that great
stuff when you hire them Renewal by
Anderson is offering a free inhome or
virtu virtual consultation on durable
quality affordable windows or patio
doors for 0 down zero payments and zero
interest for one year text nolles to 200
300 for your free consultation save 375
bucks off every window and 750 bucks off
every door these savings won't last long
so be sure to check it out text nolles
to 200 300 that is nolles to 200 300
texting privacy policy and terms and
conditions posted at text plan. us
texting enrolls for recurring automated
text message marketing and message and
data rates May apply reply stop to opt
out go to windowappointment
now.com for full offer details I know a
lot of people are asking Michael who
should be the next speaker is is Kevin
McCarthy going to run again no he said
he's not going to run again he could
have just run again maybe Whitted away
at those eight Republicans given them
more concessions and then but he says no
I don't want the job some people are
suggesting well it could be Matt Gates
Matt Gates is never going to get those
votes it maybe Jim Jordan that would be
amazing I love Jim Jordan he'd be a
terrific speaker but I like him too much
to wish such a terrible job on him
there's no no way I you know he hasn't
really expressed his desire for the job
in fact the one prominent person who has
put forward his name to be the next
speaker of the house is Matt Walsh and
so I would like to officially and fully
endorse Matt Walsh for speaker Matt has
a lot of experience in Washington I know
that he's been busy dancing but I think
that he could bring to bear all of that
work that he has done for the vice
president and others in Washington uh to
the speaker's chair to that Gabel so
Matt Walsh has my full ringing
endorsement and the top reason why I am
endorsing Matt Walsh or really anyone
over over myself because you know you
don't need to be a member of Congress to
be speaker in theory uh the reason is
because under no
circumstances would I ever seek the
speakership of the House of
Representatives because it is the single
worst job in Washington DC one would
probably rather clean out the portable
latrines on the National Mall than be
the speaker of the house it is
absolutely terrible it is hurting cats
at best and you'll be thrown out and
called a bum and called the worst person
in the world you get absolutely no glory
you get absolutely no thanks and the
recent Republican speakers have ended
their careers in
shame so no no who would want that job
why is it so bad it's not the worst job
if you're a Democrat people love Nancy
Pelosi Nancy Pelosi was able to
accomplish a lot of things not very good
things but she was able to accomplish a
lot she has a lot of influence she has a
lot of prominence in the Democrat Party
she's helped shape the Democrat agenda
she's still lauded as one of the leaders
of the party the same cannot be said of
Paul Ryan the same cannot be said of
John Boehner even n he was the most
effective one we've had in a long
time perhaps other than Kevin McCarthy
well though nuk INRI was certainly more
effective than Kevin McCarthy Kevin
mcarthy might have been a little bit
more conservative but regardless why is
it that the Democrats do better in the
job than the Republicans do the reason
is because for the Republicans it is an
impossible job because the Republican
party is split in in Far More distinct
ways than the Democrats are the
Democratic party is split
between extremely Progressive people and
slightly less Progressive people there
aren't really very many conservative
Democrats at all maybe Henry quar of
Texas would be he's probably the only
one okay so you've got the extreme
far-left liberals you got AOC and ilhan
Omar and and then you've got the
slightly less extreme ones like Nancy
Pelosi but they're all on the same page
directionally they're all facing the
same way and so it's easy to Wrangle
them with the
Republicans you've got the conservatives
mostly in the freedom caucus and then
you've got the liberals who are the
moderates who are the ones who agree
with Democrats on a lot of issues but
they're at least nominally Republican
and they vote with the Republicans on
some issues and we we want them to be
with the Republicans so that we don't
get completely blown out in these votes
but how do you reconcile those things
when it comes down to Foundation
premises of politics all of the
Democrats are on the same page when it
comes down to foundational premises of
Politics the Republicans are split you
got the
conservatives and the
Liberals and the the two will never get
all that close together so anyone who's
going to Wrangle them is going to have
to be able to be a little bit squishy
which is going to irritate the
conservatives and the conservatives
rightly are going to say well I don't
want to go along with that if if the
choice we have in Congress is between
super duper liberals and slightly less
intense liberals then what's the point
that's not a choice that's an echo and
so they're going to pull their support
boy what a great clip that was
now make sure that you ring the bell
subscribe to the Michael nolles YouTube
channel see you next time